I'm a homemaker with a chronic illness,
and I get asked a lot of times how I
managed to keep up with everything around my house
while I'm struggling with chronic illness.
This is one of my favorite tips.
When I cook,
I cook a lot of food.
I basically cook in bulk,
and then we eat on it for a few days,
because I will often have one good day
and then a few bad days,
so this saves me a lot of energy.
And then also,
um, once the food is cool,
I can freeze it and pull that out of the freezer later.
So I just try to keep stuff like this on hand. Um,
but bolt cooking is definitely one of my favorite tips.
Tonight I made a pot of cheeseburger soup,
and I should have enough leftovers to get us through
at least the next day,
maybe the day after that.